c'était la veille des vacances de noël
et la fête battait déjà son plein on
voyage en famille et on a daily sur des
vols différents maman axe pitié toute la
famille est partie faire son voyage de
rêve tout le banc des sorties au sahara
en oubliant une toute petite chose maman
papa comblé ils doivent même pas savoir
que je suis là ouais ils doivent même
pas savoir que je suis là
ma famille c'est hier à tokyo je me
retrouve carrément tout homme
[Musique]
est ce que tu te rends compte qu'à cause
de toi j'ai mon fils de 10 ans tout seul
à la maison vers simplement supposé de
max était de reprendre la route on sait
par compte et
je veux pas atterrir en taule je
tiendrai pas 30 secondes objets quand tu
arrives en taule c'est là qu'on colle
aucun de nous deux n'a finira
on est des criminels alors ça devrait
c'est ma maison je dois la défendre
la boule orange dans le coup du milieu
où
vu le bruit ça du fermage
excusez moi je dois rentrer
pour retrouver une piscine
il est tout seul
qui a besoin de moi
maman j'ai raté l'avion ça recommence
non les seuls tu crois je suis idiot ce
point
[Musique]
non exclusivement sur 10 et plus ça va
être le meilleur noël de notre avis
j'ai emmené les enfants à new york
d'avoir une comédie musicale
moi je trouve ça super et ensuite des
types ont essayé de nous tuer
quand on y pense c'est pas vraiment
super
[Musique]
il ratera loin encore une jambe ici co2
les choses se sont légèrement compliqué
c'est sûr que vous allez à tracer
évidemment c'est s'y arrête
[Musique]
bon
on est à court de flèches classique donc
ça c'est des plats chatte est piégé
vous avez encore plus mal être que ça
sérieux
[Musique]
or tu parles d'un joyeux noël
comment ça se fait que vous faites du
stop la nuit par ici
disiez que vous habitiez ici à raccoon
city car ce soit
vous êtes vous
[Musique]
la chérie il faut conserver
verrouillé les grilles
pourquoi tu es là toute cette ville a
été imposé mais
[Musique]
si on n'arrête pas
forêts contaminées le monde entier alors
on y va
c'est quoi ce bordel
un braila faisait quoi ici il faisait
des expériences c'est le travail de
toute une vie je le donnerai à personne
[Musique]
eager s'est on sait pas la langue
amour elle à détruire cette ville
tout ce que je veux c'est me tire est
ici
[Musique]
c'est bien sortir un peu vous n'entendez
à rien je suis paysagiste et j'ai une
affaire qui voulait me demander quelque
chose
ah bon parce que vous vous rapprochez
non pas du tout non
j'entends bien où l'entente rien rien
qu'est ce qu'on disait pas vous rien et
puis moi c'était pas très intéressant je
crois
tant mieux tant mieux
le père de viol à tulle où il est parti
et il est mort il va jamais l'avoir
moins depuis qu'il est mort
abandon mais vous êtes toujours à
l'ouest
j'ai par un numéro 07 54
[Musique]
vous êtes l'avocate qui plaident contre
les femmes est encore beaucoup
d'inégalités
[Applaudissements]
quand on oublie son passé ce qu'elle
fout puis
on est condamné à le revivre sans les
choses tu tiens maintenant ça saigne et
âme à une femme qui s'exprimeraient
brillamment la tribune ne pourrait être
qu'un homme
c'est un cauchemar juste en voyage un
voyage pour aller où
attache ta ceinture c'est parti
y a pas de ceinture en 64
il faut s'entraider entre femmes et nous
voulons nous exprimer retournez à vos
fourneaux
je n'ai pas peur de mourir oui bah moi
non plus chealander en maths code
quantum
en plus ils sont
ici
[Musique]
tactiquement et que
c'est
ça paye une série made you are
à toulouse comme à jamais
[Musique]
merci à tous ceux là messieurs
votre compte et a découvert au delà de
son autorisation aux enfants ils peuvent
pas vous et des logements du lotissement
avec le sourire pour crise aidant les
enfants hollandais pas question non non
on avait une quand même peut-être une
solution on a un concours de rock
montferrand a été qualifié déjà d'accord
c'est très hypothétique malgré tout
vous avez des appréhensions par rapport
à un rapport éventuel ben je sais pas
trop comment ça va se passer une
première fois est toujours douloureuse
désagréable plein de malentendus
extrêmement des sports au toit inoue
voilà
deux ministres comment il va
combien allait travailler une centaine
de milliers d'euros en tout cas j'ai
volé personne jarnac et personne au
ministre de l'économie
mais c'est le ministre est quel est
votre plus gros défaut
de dire la vérité
ne sais pas d'où ça qu'on va pas régler
le problème autour de cet homme elle a
le droit dans ses bottes clairement
gaullienne non mais je rêve
[Musique]
il faut mettre 22 milliards sur la table
alors on peut taper sur tout ce qui
bouge mais de la solidarité avant tout
on ne veut pas diviser les français on
veut bien sûr un pays uni nous voulons
tous un pays uni
[Musique]
il faut jamais être politiquement
correct
en
[Musique]
attaque
c'est calme il y aura
[Musique]
six mois
sol mais lassant à quoi sont jerry donc
en me considérant ci faisant je vous
embellissez tous les jours
mais de fouilles au repos et canaliser
un peu toute cette énergie il faut pas
me reposer à mon âge tu es mon petit
caveau est rodé elle appelle à vraiment
c'est de bon ton d'apprendre l'allemand
[Musique]
à vatan rien ne se fera sans toi
juste ferrures de choses pour eux ça
veut dire quoi ça que l'invention juif
doit être apposée à l'encré rouge chants
moqueurs d'identité
harry fou
et moi je ne suis pas mélancolique
grâce à mon change rien
vous respectez tout ce qu'ils disent
mais couture est
je t'écoute
bonjour bonjour je présente john il va
examiner taillieu qui fait semblant
d'avoir be il faudra peut-être que vous
portez des lunettes
à quel âge tu as couché pour la première
fois du match a sa vérité qu'est ce tu
vas te coucher la vedette
à savoir aussi leurs besoins évoluent
tout cas ils ont intérêt à tous nous
rendre le match peut accepter sans
[Musique]
jamais avoir peur on décide de tout dans
la vie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[ __ ] passé mais souffre plus folles je
peux t'imaginer dominique inquiétudes
fusée jouait toujours quand si on joue
des platters
à la mi juin
[Musique]
rien ni personne ne prend le dessus sur
la vie rien